there's a great line in the film to that
la men play a lot of games and I'm sure
la women have their own tricks up their
sleeves so if you were going to coach a
room of la bachelors and about going out
cheese what would you find and I don't
know I I had so many cynical jokes in my
head right there but I'll try to watch
how to do it well I mean I just say like
come on man like no pickup lines okay
just no pickup lines do not press too
hard in a situation let it come to you a
little bit and guess what if it's not
gonna be met halfway then it's not meant
to be so relaxed take an opportunity
when you see it but just like have low
expectations and you will be simply
surprised I I kind of agree with what
you're saying for women too because I
think I see a lot of my guy friends the
girls sometimes now can be so
overwhelming and really in your face and
really pushy and they don't like that
it's great for maybe one night but not
to be in relationship with and I think
that a lot of value in having
self-respect and dignity and and being
yourself don't try and act like someone
else or pretend you like all these
different things cuz the guy likes it no
be who you are likely what you like and
the right person will come along
unapologetically be yourself
yes which brings me back to the bachelor
it's like man just make this all that
laughter I mean think about it those
girls are going crazy for this guy it's
like have some self-respect